really nervous I figure if I I'm
considering myself for win if I don't
he'll show you my pants then I'll be a
winner if that doesn't happen I'm just
I'm just happy to be happy to be alive
Lamar Odom on his pre-season jitters
ahead of the upcoming Dancing with the
Stars premiere think I'm ready I'm then
practicing enough I have a great partner
and hopefully I can just of course
Odom's former sister and brother-in-law
Kym and Rob Kardashian both previously
competed on the show Kym in 2008 with
Mark Ballas as her partner she was the
third contestant to be voted off Rob had
a much better run in 2011 coming in
second place with dance Pro Cheryl Burke
but as for whether the former Lakers Pro
has asked the Kardashians for any tips
instead on Friday
Odom told Petey he's just trying to
learn as much as he can my field just
like the mannerisms are really different
from a dancer to a basketball player I'm
definitely working muscles that haven't
worked in a while and my legs but other
than that it's still a mystery to us
which dance probe the 39 year old will
hit the ballroom with she's pretty I
think she is that's it she's pretty but
he has zeroed in on his competition
james Van Der Beek he's like a hard
worker and I know Ray Lewis is really
competitive
this girl from home fifth harmony she's
like she's cheating because I know she's
danced professionally before but it's
all good I'm with it here's how Odom
says he plans to dance his way to
Miraval glory just to be consistent and
persistent and the Hat will and to face
my fear [ __ ] my life with the world and
many different aspects so just be
another side I didn't know no they
didn't know I can ballroom dance I
didn't know I can ballroom dance
hopefully are just know I'm just gonna
have fun
it's like light-hearted event and maybe
if I if I want when I win it I get to
share my message
[Music]